that's the good stuff
what's going around the internet when I
came across these mud jeans I mean they
look like a normal pair of jeans but
they are three dirties so that you can
put them on and immediately look like
you've done its work I've found myself
outside on a few occasions but I'm
definitely not a like get your hands
dirty let's build a barn type of person
yeah I kind of envious of of that
lifestyle I wish I could maybe be a
little more outdoorsy oh god they're so
dirty like oil spill meets demolition
derby Oh No these pair of jeans are four
hundred and twenty-five dollars
[Music]
I wish I could pull that off but there's
no way okay so we're gonna go try and
find some denims to DIY our own
inexpensive version so let's go like we
found the pants we've got the denim
outfit we're gonna dirty this up let's
do this
[Music]
okay so we have our denim suit we have
our blank slate here I think it's time
we try and get this as dirty as the the
expensive one but first would be a real
shame we got our hands dirty let's get
started all right so we're gonna take
this mixture here a lot a lot of pocket
work as they say in the fashion world I
think it looks pretty cool go ahead and
dirty up the knees rub that rub that
bleach in these jeans are we're gonna
smell good I think we are going to
graduate to just brown shoe polish yeah
I worry I should have worn dirtier socks
I'm just rubbing dirt on me but the look
to be fair we're definitely getting
there I mean this absolutely looks real
because it is this also looks real and
the pants I mean I think we're
definitely coming pretty close to
replicating the $900 outfit this is our
denim recreation and I think we did a
pretty good huh I am pretty amazed at
how this turned out
[Music]
this looks real this looks like I
actually had a terrible accident
this smells way worse the other one just
smells like new clothes this smells like
a garbage disposal you can buy a jacket
and regular jeans and think you can get
that sort of rugged dirty look on your
own without literally spending a month's
rent on one outfit I'm the same person I
was at before I'm a phony I gave it a
valiant effort medically it looks like
something's wrong with me that the
expensive ones still look like mud this
looks like I poop out of the front